it's good thing captain's not picking up  the tree because she keeps peeing on  everything every single one is his  [Music]  that's pretty good let's um get your arm  out of there nice  director of photography how's it look  it's pretty good your Nana will get to  see the whole experience I shall see the  trees  growing up we would go to a tree farm  and my mom actually she wouldn't have it  cut down she'd keep it with all the  roots you'll see in my backyard all of  those like pine trees are actually old  Christmas trees and they're huge now  kind of bummed we had to kill this guy  but I don't really have that kind of  space you know my upbringing with less  traditional holidays so like starting  something that is good and stable and I  don't know that I've ever really had  that sorry we're starting a new thing  here